polarlichter haben die menschheit immer
irgendwie fasziniert und sind auch heute
noch geheimnisvoll
doch die geisterhaften licht spielername
haben die menschen früher vor allem
angst eingeflößt denn die autoren
genannten irrlichter galten als vorboten
für unheil mittlerweile wissen wir das
polarlicht dadurch sonnenwinde entstehen
aber wie entstehen sie genau wie kann
man sie am besten beobachten und welche
gefahr geht von ihnen für uns menschen
aus und welches geräusch machen sie
jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
wir waren das mal als fakt ist also die
top fünf fakten über polarlichter hat
fünf so entstehen polarlichter wenn die
sonne einen sonnenwind voller energie
geladene teilchen protonen elektronen
und helium atomen ausstößt braucht
sonnenwind rund 18 stunden um das
magnetfeld der erde zu erreichen
das wird auch magnetosphäre genannt und
hält die teilchen davon ab ganz an die
erdoberfläche zu kommen weil sie vorher
eben auf diese magnetfeldlinien treffen
diese sind in richtung norden
ausgerichtet und hier wirkt dann
sogenannte lorenz kraft die die
elektrisch geladenen teilchen ablenkt
und sie um die magnetosphäre herum
leitet zudem polen die energie geladenen
teilchen verbinden sich dann mit den
erd- eigenen atom und so entstehen die
polarlichter
das alles findet in rund 100 kilometern
höhe stand also da wo der weltraum
beginnt und deutlich über der
wolkendecke
während eines sonnensturms im oktober
2003 betrug die sonnenwind
geschwindigkeit übrigens acht und
festhalten
2.000 kilometer pro sekunde fakt 4
darum sind polarlichter an den polen zu
beobachten
das magnetfeld der erde ist ja nicht
kreisrund das haben eine schule gelernt
stattdessen hat es eine apfel form mit
öffnungen oben und unten durchzogen eben
von magnet verdienen und weil die
elektronen auf grund ihrer ladung vor
allem von den öffnungen der
magnetfeldlinien angezogen werden werden
sie zu den polen gelenk polarlichter
sind übrigens an beiden enden der welt
zu sehen und zwar zur selben zeit wenn
sich also der himmel über norwegen
verfärbt gibt es auch am südpol polar
richter entsprechend nennt man sie dann
auch nordlicht oder südlich um
polarlichter zu sehen braucht es einen
klaren und dunklen himmel wenn sie
entstehen eben in rund 100 kilometern
höhe je weiter man sich von den polen
entfernt unsere seltener werden
polarlichter in deutschland sind sie
nicht wirklich oft zu sehen doch wenn
sehr starke sorgen die stürme auftreten
dann gibt sie auch bei uns so etwa vier
bis acht mal im jahr
fakt sei so entstehen die verschiedenen
farben der polarlichter vielleicht wisst
ihr dass die gewöhnlichen farben von
polarlichtern blau rot und grün sind
doch es gibt natürlich mischfarben wie
etwa weiß gelb oder violett doch wie
kommen die polarlichter an die einzelnen
farben
das hängt zum einen von der höhe ab in
der die das ereignis stattfindet aber
auch von den unterschiedlichen
bestandteilen der atmosphäre zwischen
150 und 600 kilometern sorgen
stickstoffatome für rote und blaue
farben in einer höhe von 80 bis 150
kilometern etwa da ist es sauerstoff der
grüne polarlichter entstehen lässt fakt
2 so klingen polarlichter erst im
vergangenen jahr hat ein forschungsteam
aus finnland herausgefunden welche
geräusche polarlichter produzieren sie
beschreiben es wie ein kurzes klatschen
bzw eine art peitschenhieb das wird wohl
vom sonnenwind verursacht und zwar
vorher war nicht mal klar dass sie
überhaupt ein geräusch machen eine
bedingung dafür ist aber auch dass eine
bestimmte wetterlage auf der erde
herrscht genannt wird sie
inversionswetterlage beispielsweise bei
starkem frost dann ist es am boden
kälter als in den luftschichten darüber
in 70 metern höhe etwa liegt die trends
schicht zwischen den warmen und den
kalten luftmassen 170 meter am boden und
genau hier sammeln sich all die
geladenen teilchen von der erdoberfläche
und wenn dann ungefähr 100 kilometern
höhe ein polarlicht entsteht
wechselwirken diese elektrisch geladenen
teilchen mit den ionen in der luft die
beteiligten forscher fanden außerdem
heraus dass eine art entladung des
magnetischen feldes passiert wenn die
geladenen teilchen des sonnenwindes auf
die erdatmosphäre treffen etwa 0,2
sekunden nach der magnetfeld änderung
hatte das forschungsteam dieses
klatschen der polarlichter aufnehmen
können berechnet haben sie dann dass die
geräuschquelle 70 bis 80 meter über dem
boden liegen muss und das entspricht
genau der sogenannten inversion schicht
weil bei dieser inversionswetterlage
fakt eins polarlichter können fatale
folgen für uns haben ja auch wenn es ein
tolles naturspektakel ist es hat seine
schattenseiten denn an den polarregionen
schützt das eigene erdmagnetfeld weniger
manche experten sagen dass es bei
aktuellen sonneneruptionen sinnvoll sei
verkehrsflugzeuge andere routen fliegen
zu lassen das machen sie auch außerdem
können solche starken spannungsfeld auch
die funktion von forschungs- und
kommunikationssatelliten stören indem
sie die messdaten oder signale zur erde
stören in der alaska pipeline hatten
forschungsteams elektrische ströme von
einigen 1000 ampere gemessen
allein durch die wirkung des polarlicht
das radio funk und satelliten navigation
können ausfallen genauso wie ganze
stromnetze
der schaden für die wirtschaft und
infrastruktur ist jedes mal enorm und
beträgt schätzungen zufolge 48
milliarden us dollar täglich und zwar
nur in den usa
und solche zwischenfälle hat es ja schon
öfter gegeben wir haben hier ja schon
darüber berichtet super sonnenstürme
gefährden die erde
den link zum video gibt es am ende
dieses videos wenn er keine videos zu
den drohnen gefahren durch sonnenstürme
und zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann
umgeht er die kaputte abo box hier auf
youtube und verpasst keinen werfer papa
passt kein video mehr
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
und noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken man am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks um social and
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür hier
klicken aber nicht die genau die glocke
vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken super sonnenstürme treffen
unausweichlich die erde bis dann bleibt
dran